[Music]
an experimental gene-therapy for a rare
hereditary form of blindness is a step
closer to reality an FDA advisory panel
voted unanimously yesterday to recommend
approval of a groundbreaking treatment
for people with a faulty gene that
impairs vision it would be the first
gene therapy in the US for an inherited
disease the retinal disorder known as
LCA causes severe vision loss starting
in childhood 27 of 29 patients in the
clinical trial saw functional
improvements in their sight 17 year old
Christian Guardino had the procedure
four years ago he and his mother Beth
say it's given him a new life I've been
kind of seeing new things and
experiencing new things and just like a
four year old is still learning how to
use his vision properly I'm still
learning how to use it today it's it's
been life-altering I mean completely
life-altering for in every sense for him
our dr. David agus is here with how this
treatment could be a new frontier in
treating genetic disorders good morning
good morning so exciting how does this
gene therapy work this treatment it's
pretty amazing you know you inherit two
chromosomes one from the mother one from
the father in this case one of the
parents had a mutation and it's protein
or gene didn't work and so they
inherited a faulty one from each parent
so here they take a virus and they put
in a normal copy of the gene and they
inject it into the white of the eye and
then literally days later site returns
to most of the people in the trial and
it's an amazing thing I mean this is the
start of a new revolution now I notice
this is cool for me to say I used a cool
hashtag this morning science fiction
science because it really is something
we dreamed of and talked about for
decades but now it's happening is this
CRISPR no Christopher correct something
that's already there this is taking a
normal one and putting it in to replace
the function that was missing I was
stunned to read that the entire
procedure lasts just 45 minutes right it
affects just a small number of people
though this mutation what does this mean
for other diseases gene therapy this is
about two thousand people in the United
States several thousand around the world
but there are another 500 disorders
behind this where the people are
developing treatments based on but one
shot and it's lasting up to four years
now hopefully it's forever so where does
he get the gene that is the replacing
gene so we took a normal copy from a you
know a normal individual you and I have
a normal copy of this gene they took
that out and they put it into a virus
because a virus can deliver it to cells
that are sitting there and that virus
delivers the cell that makes the protein
that's missing and the retinal cells can
go back to having vision what and what
does this mean in terms of the future of
medicine I think it means a lot I mean
obviously we can correct these genetic
disorders but you know you saw it two
months ago now they've used the same
technology to take immune cells out of a
child and put them back in and it
attacks their leukemia so we're at the
forefront of a next stage of Medicine
which is rewriting the code for good are
these for only single gene disorders so
this is for single gene disorders yeah
and you know there are a lot in this
line fibrosis sickle cell yep
and they're gonna be more down that road
and so the Lorenzo's oil one that was
you know the next one that's coming down
the road Wow and this is very costly
hopefully the price will go down I hope
so thank you dr. David egg it's always
good to see you